Speaker 1: As of yesterday, April 19th, every
American is now eligible for the coronavirus
vaccine within the age range is approved for
each vaccine.
That's 18 plus for the Moderna vaccine, 18
plus for the Johnson and Johnson vaccine paused
but expected to be resumed as soon as Friday
possibly and 16 plus for the Fizer vaccine.
This was originally going to sort of be sometime
this summer for full eligibility.
Then Joe Biden announced it would be May 1st.
Then Joe Biden announced in March that it
would be pushed up to April 19th.
And we are there and it really couldn't come
at a better time for two different reasons,
at least two different reasons.
First of all, in some states, demand is slackening
for vaccines.
States with more Republicans, 43 percent of
whom do not plan to get this vaccine, have
more vaccine hesitancy.
And so they are starting to see in some sense,
more supply and demand.
And so opening vaccination eligibility to
more people will hopefully boost vaccination
numbers and keep going with vaccinating, you
know, three to four million people per day.
Secondly, because of the Johnson and Johnson
vaccine being paused, vaccine numbers have
been slightly declining and we want to keep
things going.
The U.S. is still averaging a very strong
three point one nine, just short of three
point two million vaccine doses per day.
And we want to grow that number.
And thirdly, expanding eligibility to all
adults and then 16 plus for the Pfizer vaccine
is important because we are really in a race
against variants which some countries are
winning, and we want to get there, too.
There is a lot of doom and gloom about the
variants, the variants.
Nothing, nothing works.
It's just a disaster.
If you look at cases and deaths in the UK,
the source of the British be one one seven
variant cases are now down to 96 per day.
That's not 96 per capita is just 96 cases
per day.
That is down I'm sorry.
The cases are down 96 percent from their peak
in mid-January.
If you look at Israel, another highly vaccinated
country cases are now down more than 98 percent.
And these are countries with many variants.
When you look at a country like Israel and
in Israel, it's been all vaccination.
They are around 56 percent fully vaccinated.
Around 50 percent cases started to fall off
a cliff and go close to zero.
In the UK, the vaccination has been more modest,
but the guidelines have been significant and
the UK is actually only 15 percent fully vaccinated,
but at 50 percent partial.
And that is absolutely huge as well.
In the U.S. right now, we are at twenty five
percent fully vaccinated and 40 percent partially
as of a few days ago.
Numbers probably a little bit better by now.
Based on that, we are probably, if we can
keep this going, 30 or so days.
Remember, two weeks ago we said it was probably
35 to 45 days.
We are probably about thirty days from significant
improvements here, but people need to get
vaccinated.
And now with full eligibility, hopefully that
will happen.
My 17 year old sister got her first dose this
week.
Just about everybody I know has had one dose
already.
Things are moving in the right direction.
Now, sadly, one poll says it's 20 percent.
Another says it's 30 percent.
At least 20 percent of the country simply
doesn't want the vaccine.
And most of them are Republicans, 43 percent
of Republicans, as we talked about last week
and I mentioned earlier, do not want the vaccine.
And that's a major problem.
Now, over time, with more and more colleges
saying if you want to come back to campus,
you need a vaccine, more and more venues and
businesses and even foreign countries saying
if tourists want to come here, they will need
to be vaccinated.
Hopefully these numbers will improve.
Just get your vaccine.
Don't lose sleep over the Magga clowns.
For now, 80 percent is still enough for herd
immunity.
Let's do what we can now and then deal with
the people who selfishly will not get vaccinated
due to ignorance, due to disdain, due to political
misunderstandings, due to conspiracy ism,
whatever the case may be.
Let's keep going.
We have potentially authorization coming for
multiple vaccines for the 12 to 15 and 12
to 17 age ranges for the respective vaccines
tests being done to look at expanding it even
further.
So all of this is going in the right direction
for now.
I mean, listen, I've said before I get it,
it's frustrating to see people who could get
vaccinated and who say I'm not going to and
they could spread it and then they could give
it to somebody who's not able to get the vaccine
or who is in the five percent that buy by,
you know, odds don't develop immunity.
And then some of those people will die like
I get it, but let's focus on what we can control
and now that we have full vaccine eligibility,
you can get vaccinated.
That's the most important thing.
And we're going to continue following what
happens with JMJ and what happens with vaccine
hesitancy and the whole thing